Apple Finally Revealed the 10th
generation iPad that we have been
waiting for but it is Peak stupidity at
least for what they're offering to the
people and some of the insane choices
that they have made we're gonna be going
over that as well as some of the awesome
benefits of this new iPad and you guys
know that we already purchased one we're
gonna be comparing it to the previous
budget iPad and the iPad air so make
sure you guys are subscribed starting
out with the design you guys see these
new colors now I actually like that they
pop more but not everybody will and if
you think that this looks practically
like the iPad Air well that is exactly
right it is practically an iPad Air 4.
we have those flat sides and an even
bezel all around so no we do not get the
touch ID sensor on the front like we had
in the rumors and renders instead we
have that larger Touch ID button that is
on one of the flat sides and powering
this new iPad we have the A14 chip so
it's basically the same as the iPad Air
4. we also have stereo speakers when
it's being used in landscape and that's
a huge upgrade from the previous budget
iPad being mono and I'm really curious
to hear how they sound are they gonna be
as good or are they going to be limited
the same thing goes with that A14 is it
going to be full performance or could it
be slowed down some people are already
saying that it is that's something we're
definitely going to check out in our
full comparison and as far as the
display it looks like the same exact
display from that iPad but this is where
stuff starts to get weird and gets even
weirder now the display is the same but
if we take a closer look we do not have
P3 color accuracy which that panel
actually has now even worse this display
is non-laminated which was one of our
biggest complaints about the 9gen iPad
and that means there's a gap between uh
the touch layer and the panel uh one it
doesn't look great but even worse it
lowers your contrast it's definitely
noticeable and you have a lot more
reflectivity this also makes it not as
good for using the apple pencil and it's
interesting that even an Apple's
marketing video they show a delay when
using the apple pencil now if you notice
something weird about that video you're
right because apple is limiting this
design to the original apple pencil not
the apple pencil 2 which snaps on
magnetically it pairs automatically and
it charges quickly that way you use the
original one that has a lightning
connector with this iPad that is
straight up a limitation that they're
doing on purpose and the crazier thing
is that you cannot pair your apple
pencil to this new iPad without using an
adapter to get it to pair and using a
cable to charge it up and pair it now
what's even crazier is that in the Box
for this new iPad they are not including
that adapter you have to buy it for nine
dollars separately which I was gonna do
because I have an apple pencil but it
doesn't come until
November now if you buy a brand new old
apple pencil from Apple they will
include that adapter in the box if you
go spend 100 bucks so I was gonna do
that because I had to I wanted to get it
quicker but that also doesn't ship out
till November this is just insane that
they're blocking the apple pencil too
from working you gotta use your old one
but you can't unless you go and spend
some extra money if this was just some
kind of Hardware limitation with that
display why not include the adapter in
the Box because you only need the
adapter for this iPad but no they rather
make some extra money and I think that
is just a shame and with that if you
don't already know the price it is
450 dollars 450 bucks compared to 329
where a lot of times we had sales for
299 or even lower so some people were
complaining about prices going up to 350
or 399 this is 450 and if you want to
get 128 gig version you can't you have
to go to 256 and that's another 150
dollars so this thing is getting crazy
expensive so if you're spending that
much why don't you just get an iPad Air
fifth generation you can actually buy
one brand new for 519 dollars not a big
step up and you get a lot of other
improvements with that including you
know better processing with that M1 chip
even better you can buy an iPad Air 4
refurbished with a 90-day money-back
guarantee from Amazon for 429 dollars
and that uses the same processor it has
you know good speakers you can use the
new Apple pencil it is laminated you
have P3 wide color accuracy and you're
spending less money I'll leave the links
to those down in the description below
now the only thing that really makes
this one more desirable is the fact that
they put the camera in landscape mode
now now you don't have face ID or
anything you have that touch ID but if
you're using it landscape or with a
keyboard you're going to look much more
normal compared to even the brand new
iPad Pro that they just announced where
if you're looking screen it looks like
you're looking off way to the side it
also has Center Stage which is nice you
get a wider image that can crop in and
with that they released a brand new
keyboard called the magic keyboard folio
now this thing looks really great you
have a full row of function keys which
is really nice to have the keys have one
millimeter of travel so that is great
and you can detach the keyboard portion
from the back that can stay on for
protection and you have your adjustment
angle built into that as well now Apple
says a brand new unique keyboard but if
you guys remember the Folio keyboard
from Logitech well that thing was 99
bucks for the budget iPad it looked very
similar had the same connector mechanism
that you could take apart this is not
super unique it's basically a copy of
that but get this it is
250 dollars for this keyboard which is
crazy now I know it's going to be a
great keyboard but it doesn't have that
floating design of the magic keyboard uh
and that floating design was awesome it
brings the screen closer to you you can
adjust it so that is one expensive
keyboard for a budget iPad now overall I
have to say that adding those Theory
speakers having a landscape camera the
new design a lot of people are going to
be happy with especially if they are
okay with sticking with that 64 gigabyte
model uh that's 450 bucks if you can
afford it and uh you don't need the
extra features or extra performance of
the higher end ones well you're gonna be
happy with it uh especially if you don't
need the apple pencil or if you don't
use that but just because they raise the
price by a lot and they added these
things which we know it's they're
specifically limiting what this thing
can do with that non-limited display
with the apple pencil with some of the
other stuff it just makes it really a
shame and it just sounds very dumb and
very you know Peak stupidity to lock
these things down when they absolutely
don't have to be and Apple's raising at
the price by that much maybe if they
kept it 3.99 or you know personally I'd
be even happy with that leaked design
which has the touch ID button if they
would keep the price at 350 379 maybe
make it not as nice in a way especially
if they're limiting it to the first
generation apple pencil I think that'd
be much more reasonable but at this
point I would just buy an iPad Air 4
that is refurbished for Less it is more
capable overall and as long as you just
don't need that landscape camera so I
think a lot of people are kind of
disappointed with this maybe even more
disappointed with the iPad Pro that was
just refreshed you guys don't your
thoughts down in the comment section
below click that Circle above to
subscribe so you guys don't miss out our
video on the iPad Pro and what has
changed and what hasn't check out one of
those great videos right over there this
is Max and I'll see you in the next one
[Music]